so have a coach to catch this morning at
6:50 I woke up at 5:30 no problem
I then fell back asleep how'd I guess
understatement to get to the bus station
this is getting very close
I've got a flight
it's just walkable does 501 so it
through to London all right made it to
Heathrow now this is like a Casey
Neistat vlog but worse there's only one
point on this board as far as I can tell
this delayed and guess where I'm going
so I'm flying to Berlin to hip hop in a
video initiative run by a German company
called Merck which is pharmaceuticals
company and they wanted to a video
campaign about curiosity and the fly me
out to be interviewed about basically
kind of how I mix doing PhD stuff and
video stuff and how I embody can
curiosity and both made all the more
attractive by the fact that I'm beating
two people on my friend an ace so that's
where I'm going
tell me for the cake
[Music]
so I'm in Berlin with an ace even met an
ace in Amsterdam you only crop up in
other European cities I know so an ace
is interviewing me tomorrow you been to
Berlin before
okay which is did she's winning okay
this is the situation my two years of
secondary school German has prepared me
for I can read basic food labels no
grammar is necessary I just need to know
what case it is oh this is completely
undone my point because it's in English
okay okay so this hotel room is pretty
nice I guess and where's the lights uh
yeah this is all right I guess this a
changing room oh my god
that's a shower and we just go down the
steps into my shower that's metal and it
blocks the view from the window speaking
of which there's a balcony out there
there was a rather attractive lady who
was just dressed in a dressing-gown
nothing else who just disappeared
take another spoon what is this why is
all this about what my own slippers of
course so I showed you my bathroom we
have the bed which I'm guessing is gonna
be better than sleeping on a mattress on
the floor in here we also have the TV we
have the entertainment laid on outside
on the balcony let me just take you
through the living room portion of my
room with a sofa and another TV because
you know what kind of plebeian only has
one minibar a kitchenette thing I don't
even know it's just a brilliant well
isn't this just nuts I woke up past 5:00
this morning on the ground in Exeter I'm
now you know like a luxury hotel room in
Germany nobody told you that was gonna
be this way
right so I just gone out to dinner with
the guys from work and now got a couple
of hours before I go to bed I'm gonna
make use of that shower for sure and all
the free stuff they given me but I also
now need to prepare some stuff this
interview which I've already done I'd
like to point out but I just want to
spend a little bit of time writing down
some answers
that's I think you're gonna come up I
feel like I'm witnessing a great natural
migration there's been a stream of bikes
this intense for the past I don't even
know how long as much of techno music as
well oh it's the it's the rozzers
evening officers okay if you live in
Berlin and can explain what this is all
about please dude have you know
and good morning so it is about
half-past seven
I definitely did not sleep enough last
like I was up quite late finishing off
these questions I am a little bit woozy
but really excited because I'm going to
go be driven out to this location in
about 15 minutes which it's got some
interesting history associated with it
I'm really curious just to do this
interview I want to see how an ace is
going to do it
oh there is a very real possibility that
I'm just gonna pop a technology boner
all this kit so this is the location
with filming at the interview this
morning now this may look like Russian
village kind of a wooden structure but
it's not we're actually still in Berlin
but we're in Potsdam which is in the
east which means I think apart from it
briefly came here for conference but I
spent the entire time in hotel I think
this is the first time I've ever been
behind the Iron Curtain like in the all
Soviet Union which is pretty cool I'm
pretty sure I just saw the director
drive off that doesn't feel like a good
omen so what time did you wake up this
morning an aim-7 49
why did you wake up well I didn't
exactly wake up until you were banging
on my door I was an active the landlord
today so we were supposed to be
downstairs at 7:45 Ifill once was on
time as a live will attest I am always
late but I was there like 7:35
that's a nice mare come true and like I
had the alarm set for every day except
Saturday and two days of Saturday so
yeah I just ran upstairs nice and you
were like why is anyone why is this
person waking everybody up at 6:00 in
the morning I know and then you open the
door a crack it was a little face a
pillow thing can you give me five
minutes
that's the important thing
and we're now here in Potsdam at the
Russian colony and we got here early
anyway fine
I never just stand up for you you're
pointing matter right I think we're
about to start shooting our set of
external 's outside this house
yeah so I don't have a huge amount of
experience working with this kind of
crew like multiple people but it does
definitely bring home just how quick it
is to do your own YouTube videos when
you're doing everything yourself because
but they'll shoot something that it's
not even necessarily complex it's this
level with this much money involved that
people want to get it exactly right so
we've just done like five takes of just
the initial shot so yeah man thank you
us how lucky you are as a youtuber do
you definitely don't get such a nice kit
hey guys wanna middle it'll set you do
you fella edu okay so that's all of our
exteriors done we're now going to for
the magic of movies pretend that we went
into the house that which is a museum
but we were outside we're actually gonna
go into a different house which looks
nice though hello darkness my friend
which looks nicer on the inside a little
bit behind schedule and now we're inside
this place is kind of strange this is
deep inside of the restaurant living the
Russian cause the Russian village well
strange
you see the positions I'm really looking
forward to having just a normal chat
with my friend an aged way with all
these people are happy
[Music]
okay done at this location
so I should probably explain about this
place by the way because I've learned a
bit about it in museum basically this is
it's called the Russian colony it was
built on the order of a Prussian Emperor
to accommodate Russian musicians I think
it was actually singers specifically and
so it's in the middle of well on the
outskirts of Berlin but it looks like
it's a little rural Russian village with
lots of trees and stuff that deer is
we're here because it communicates you
know if you look at life from the wrong
perspective your draw the wrong
conclusions so you know we're zoomed in
too far you're thinking I'm Russia if
you zoom all the way out you'll see
you're actually in Germany very cool
place gotta say I wish I could
understand everything was in the museum
because I could only pick out from her
oh there's an English bit here
there you go pause that everyone know
the history I'll definitely say it's an
interesting new experience of being
interviewed this way we just did three
takes of me trying to answer four
questions and basically the same way but
how creativity basically saying yeah
talk about creativity would basically do
the same thing again please
which of course is just how it works
it's kind of strange like to be even
like slightly the center of attention in
somebody else's production because
obviously in vlogs I'm the center of
attention because I make it write the
theme tune sing the theme tune you know
all that kind of stuff but yeah kind of
strange
I don't feel important enough to deserve
this treatment a German lady just
grabbed my boob clean like I said a
German lady just rubbed it out so so I
yeah so I started and she was like no no
no you have to rub and she like you know
six a hand-up starts with me so nice
just at our walk and talk throughout the
park realized by the way so UNESCO World
Heritage Site so that's pretty nifty I
would say and now we're getting to a
shop is gonna cause me some personal
grief
[Music]
they ask you how you are you just have
to say that you're fine when you're not
really fine but you just can't get into
it because they would never understand
okay and with that outro done it's
filming done bit over schedule but these
things happen
shape is a like a natural much getting
pretty worried about my PhD carried I
kind of want to get back to work out
okay so back at the hotel because I need
to charge my phone because I am not
trusting my sense of direction I need
Google Maps I am going to try and make
the most of the next about two hours I
have 15 closes and seeing Berlin I mean
when in Rome Berlin okay so that whole
plan for looking around Berlin didn't
really work out because I wasn't gonna
lead the room without my phone because I
was gonna get lost and I needed to put
charge in it but the time the phone was
charged literally all the museums were
closing so there was no point in me
coming out and the crew from the shoot
because I was a second interview
happening we're gonna be arriving so I
just didn't need the room I feel kind of
guilty about that but at the same time
if I'd left I would have just got lost
and I might have had an adventure but I
probably wouldn't have found my way back
so unfortunately I've actually been in
Berlin and I've not really seen very
much of it which is a shame because it
seems like a very nice place not Palin
here for sure oh yeah hotels a free
supply suite downstairs totally abusing
that also the hotel's free slippers
weren't big enough for my feet
nicely broken them the sins I put them
on oh well great shower though
[Music]
okay so I've got about an hour before I
get picked up and taken to the airport
so that leaves me about an hour to try
and cram and as much about them as I can
which won't be much but I think the best
way to see the history is gonna be to go
to the museum quarter okay family your
mum buys their clothes it's quite funny
to me like hell because my gem is quite
basic I can't understand what a lot of
things say like this after some adverts
on the other hand I guess there are just
some Universal things in life like
dildos so this is the berliner dom this
is the cathedral one of my favorite
pieces of music we thought recently was
actually the Berliner nests by our by
pet if you've watched the Avengers age
of Ultron you've heard bit of it it's
when a spoilers Quicksilver dies
not bhakti Drakkar say
unfortunately have to pay to get in
which I completely understand
and I'd have any euros at a time so the
noise I'm gonna get out of this building
is just looking in from the outside
which isn't exactly bad I mean if I'm
being honest a lot of the bests the
religious Christian music comes from
Germany so it's hardly surprising now
such a nice Cathedral we'd love to have
gone inside though this square that MN
actually seems to sort of summarize my
experience of Berlin so far the limited
experience is you've got Peter you've
got that library and museum and then on
its side you've got River but then on
this side you've got massive road leads
of buildings modern stuff like Berlin
definitely feels like Berlin definitely
feels like it's kind of capturing this
staying true to its old self but it's
also moving forwards it's very much
future looking you can sort of get that
impression just you know just from the
buildings in the square but also just I
don't know they kind of feel I like you
I want to come back alright so I don't
have very much time or lighting so I'm
gonna try and head to the Pergamon
Museum which was what Stephen the
postdoc and my office recommended I do
I'm stopping because I was taking a
picture right for good
[Music]
because it's a museum basically really
old stuff and I love really old stuff
[Music]
damn it you have to pay for that one as
what else again completely
understandable I'm just doing this on a
student budget and student time
[Music]
was I not invited that's a beauty ring
I need that okay question why does every
major tourist if you have one of these
even if they didn't necessarily have a
dungeon like as one of London is one an
Amsterdam I'm pretty sure every major
European city I've been to has had a XYZ
dungeon any thoughts of genes were not a
good idea today is very hot to be honest
I would have loved to have gone to the
wall or the remains of the wall and also
and like so many other places basically
only had an hour and a lot these places
were further away and I would have spent
like ten minutes there whereas there
lots of places I could sort of see the
outsides of on a walking tour just sort
of near the hotel so sorry Berlin people
if you're watching this and Chris
screaming at me for not making the most
of your city I really like it I do want
to come back I was just in the wrong
place with not enough time I think if I
was to compare Berlin to any UK city it
feels quite a bit like Manchester it's
strange
like it's definitely captain City it's
not like Madrid where you probably
wouldn't be able to guess that it's a
capital it feels like kind of Manchester
mixed with Vienna the best way I can
like create some monstrous hybrid
there's a lot of green here as well as a
bit like Amsterdam actually in a few
ways like I found XD Luigi
something that was really keen to learn
about in Berlin was how events at the
Second World War and the Nazi Party were
not commemorated that's the wrong word
but remembered I guess because obviously
not everybody who was part of Germany at
the time who's an evil person you know
most the people were just normal people
trying to go about their lives and it
was a hateful ideology that was kind of
spread by certain people that let the
whole country to war it wasn't
everybody's fault obviously and so it
I've totally been interesting to try and
learn how the actions of individuals
like the brave of individual soldiers
who were undoubtedly incredibly brave
how that gets commemorated in the
context of a completely barbaric regime
unfortunately I hadn't had time to go to
a museum but I was just reading on the
outside of the new synagogue which
wasn't something I was aware of where I
came here and basically this is a
synagogue and he was the biggest in all
of Prussia
when Prussia was the thing that was hit
during the war and were it burns before
because of the events of Kristallnacht
and
basically it's been reconstructed after
it's well the facade has full synagogue
hasn't been but it was very very
interesting learning the history on the
outside and seeing how the events were
covered I'll include like footage over
this we want to read it you can pause
but it's very touching too because
obviously you learn about things like
the Holocaust in school but to actually
see a physical space to know that there
was torture that was going on underneath
that building really brings another
dimension to it when I come back I
definitely want to learn more about this
so I totally forgot that I had whatever
I go I have cutlery in my bag like I
have the knife and fork the spoon
because I'll work and it's just easy
about in the my back I forgot to take
him out didn't raise any problems at
Heathrow here I went through security
and like have you got a frog in your bag
no it turns out he met knife and I think
he was expecting like know if you you
call that a knife it wasn't it was it
was my pathetic little English cutlery
knife well if he did actually say a set
something in German to another guy he
was like that spoon I say you applied
knife a spoon II before
[Music]
vas-y ran out sorry back in Exeter I
just popped home briefly to charge
everything and now I'm going to see live
because I'm Cena for a couple of days
and to round off the vlog got a say as
weekend's go definitely one the stranger
ones I've had but spending 48 hours in
Berlin was fun actually
thank you very much to Merc who sent me
out there and for a good interview when
it's available I will link it down there
for sure if it's already out I'll be
down there and my I know there's an
annotations anymore
ignore me it'll be down there because an
ace did a good job preparing for it and
I think it's gonna come out really well
there's also gonna be a video about
curiosity coming out on this channel at
some point when I work out what that's
going to be come on camera you're
expensive focus I'm the star of the show
I felt really well taken care of the
whole time so nice one man what I say if
your ever offers to do an interview buy
them say yes they're really great I
apologize if all of this is slightly out
of focus by the way I think my camera is
learning how to deal with low-light is
the first time I've shot with this thing
on the street like this anyway I am now
very keen to get to work early tomorrow
so it's going to be relatively early
night yeah quite anxious to get back to
the code but I'm actually sort of on the
plane and like risk being away it's
given me some ideas to try it so fingers
crossed this little bug which I'm pretty
sure it's just to do with have
implemented one function in Python will
all be cleared out I really hope so
thanks very much for watching if you
enjoyed the vlog definitely give it a
like and comment with what I probably
should have done in Berlin maybe and
subscribe if you are new here also if
that Merc interview is out it will be on
the screen up here somewhere and down
there in the description and I think
it'd be really good even though
I'm trying to film a video here
[Music]